はい それでは今日の話を始まります
じゃあ皆様方はね まあクリスマスに頭がかなり興奮しているところで
仏教の話がちょっと場が間違っていると思われるかもしれませんけど
まあ今日はあの 何でしたっけ？忘れるということがテーマなんですね
忘年会やるときは参考にしてください
はい で 記憶の取り扱いを
あの このタイトルをね
立ち方なんかに付けた時はいくつかの説明文書あったと思います
私はだいたいこの説明文章の説明はいたしません
そこから話を始めます
もうとっくに読まれていらっしゃいますからね
そこからなんです 本当にいろいろ物事を忘れることをできなくて
結構困ったりすることは人間によくありますので
これはかなり大変な問題なんですね
はっきり言えば 我々はこの
忘れられなくて困っていることなんですね
いつでも困っているというのは過去のことでしょうに
過去のことをなかなか過去の失敗やらいろんなことをね
なかなか忘れることできなくて
思い出すと悩むとかね
だからまあ大変な大きな問題なんですね
人間にとっては なんかきれいさっぱり明るく明らかにという状態でね
生活できないのかっていうこと
仏教はすごく穏やかな
安穏で楽しい 明るく笑顔が絶えないように生きる生きられる技が何なのかということを教えているんです
だから それがかなり難しい心理学になってますから
誰もやりたがらないだけで
だったら勝手に苦しんでくださいというしかないんですけどね
苦しみも嫌だけど 苦しみを直すのもやりたくないという態度ですからね
とにかく 今日もちょっとそういうことで難しい話になるかもしれませんだけど
できるだけ簡単に喋ります
えーと まず覚える仕組みからいきなりこの内容に入ります
覚えるって何なのかね
記憶するって何なのかと
で 心は基本的に無明と渇愛があります
生命っていうのは この心があるんだから生命というんですね
心っていうのは無明と渇愛なんですね
基本的なエネルギーが
で ここって無明っていうのはわかります
渇愛も結構仏教専門用語はもう説明しません
もう面倒くさい もうかなり使ってますからね
これはわかりやすく言えば生きていきたいという感情なんですね
渇愛っていうのはもう渇かない
いわゆる渇きなんですね
これ パーリ語でタンハという言葉なんですけど
どうもなかなか満たせないんですね
これ 私たち渇愛はわかりませんよ
お釈迦様がおっしゃっただけなんです
我々知っているのは生きていきたいんですよ
では どこまで生きていきたいんですかね
これが正直わからないんですね
どこまででも生きていきたいんですね
とにかくはっきりと永遠不滅になりたいんです
だから この渇愛は宗教ではよく表してますよ
お釈迦様だけ渇愛という否定的な言葉を使ってますけど
宗教はそう否定的な言葉を使いませんね
かなり肯定的で では なんじらに永遠不滅になる方法を教えてあげるぞということになっちゃうんですね
だからこれはただ心の無明に燃料をあげるだけ
みんなこの餌を食っちゃうんです
永遠になりたい だから
どんな嘘でも信じちゃうんですね
宗教って言って信仰しているのは神話でしょ？ほとんど作り話でしょ
歴史的な人物もいないし
もう歴史的に語られたっていうそういう記録もないしね
全部もう作り話ですね
ブッダの言葉みたいに精密に
この場所でこういうふうに語れましたとかね
そういう客観的にどんな学者にも調べることできるふうな史実ではないんですね
ヒンドゥー教はもう明らかに神話物語ばっかり
キリスト教のね あの本は随分は百年
百年というイエスという方が亡くなってから
もういろんなところでもうもう三百ぐらい本があったんですよ
これでこのエジプトで誰かさんがね
勝手に二十四冊に決めただけで
それ一つもイエスの直々の話ではないんですね
で 学者いうのは調べたら実在の架空人物だと記録ないんだと
どこにも ギリシアで出来上がった架空人物だと思っているんだから
ちゃんと学者はね だから宗教という一応ね
まあ古い宗教を見たらね
まあよくわかるでしょう
神話物語なんですね でも我々はそこはすごくありがたく信仰するんですね
なぜかというと こんな科学世界でね
そんなのはいい アホやと捨てちゃえばいいんですけど
なかなかありがたくて捨てられないんですね
この気持ちがこの心にある渇愛なんですね
いくらなんでも永遠不滅になりたい
不死になるならば毒でも飲んじゃうという
中国の誰か誰かさんがね
水銀とか飲んだり死んじゃったみたいですからね
これ飲んだら永遠不良長寿になるんだぞとかね
これはお釈迦様が見事にこの否定形の言葉で渇愛と捨てるものであると説かれているんですね
はい それはいいんだけど
まあ私たちもまあ死にたくはないでしょう
正直なところは 生きるために
死を避けるために物事を覚えるんです
そこで覚えるという機能が出てくるんです
あれは生きるためなんです
それから いくら生きていきたいと思っても
我々は目を隠して盲目状態で生きていても
一旦生まれてみたら 目を覚ましてみたら
生きていられない環境なんです
どんなものでも 自分を生かすものよりは
自分を殺しにかかってくることっていうのはありすぎなんです
外は寒いでしょ もし外で寝る羽目になったらどうなると思いますかね
動物と同じく どこかで
木の下で 道路のそばで寝ることになっちゃったと
まあ明日ちょっと命わからないんですよ
だから世の中でいっぱい植物やら果物やら木の実あるんだけど
食べたら危ないでしょ
我々食べられるものはほんのわずかなものしかないんですね
木の実なら何でも食えるわけないでしょ
芋なら何でも食べられるわけないでしょ
だから この無数の植物の中で食べられるものだけ選ばなくちゃあかんでしょ
これ忘れちゃったら大変なことになりますよ
まあ例えば あの あれ キャベツやらね
このどころじゃなくて
あのレタスとかに似ている
もっとかっこいい植物がありますね
いろんなところでこの花の代わりに育ててますね
いろんな色もありますけど
緑やら赤やら黄色やら
あれ見る限りキャベツではないかと思っちゃうんですね
私たち食べてるキャベツは全然かっこよくないんですよ
レタスも全然かっこよくないんですね
しかし あの花壇で育てている
あの美しい あの あれ見て
これも食べられるんじゃないかといって食べたらどうなることか
よくわからない 私も あれは毒かどうかわかりませんだけど
だから私たちには死を避けるために
生きているために覚えておかないといけないことなんかは結構あるんですよ
だから覚えるんです かっこ悪いんですよ
渇愛っていうのは貪瞋痴として機能します
皆様方は渇愛はよくわからないんだけど
よくこれ機能すると だから我々の心が渇愛にログインすると貪瞋痴になるんです
ログアウトすると無明と渇愛なんです
渇愛は我々は心にログインすると
貪瞋痴としてデータが出してくるので
貪っていうのは欲 瞋っていうのは怒り
痴っていうのはどうでもいいやと
無関心という気持ちですね
地に覚える能力がないので
むさぼりと怒りに怒りという 2つの感情に刺激されて心は物事を覚えるんです
だから皆さんも結構相当な知識人でしょ
あれ 欲と怒りで やったもんですけど
全然かっこよくないんですよ
胸張れません 私はこの者やとか知識人だとかね
私は博士だとかね 何々研究員やとかね
だから知識がかなりレベル高いんだったら
怒りも欲も一般人よりは桁違いってことなんですよ
で 覚えられないんですよ
データがたくさんありますね
だから我々はこのデータを心に引っかかって止めてもらわなあかんですね
だからなんかフックだと思ってください
フックにカバンとかコートとかかけておくでしょ
そのように心にフックみたいなものあるんですね
これは貪瞋痴なんですね
痴っていうのはフックが下向いてるんですね
だから何もかけられないんです
ただ面倒くさいだけ 場所を取ってるんです
壁いっぱいフックがあるんだけど
もう大半が下向いてるんです
だから上向いてるフックには何かかけられますよ
帽子とかベルトとかネクタイとかね
そこで心に欲と怒りというフック 2つあって
そちらにデータが引っかかるんです
そちらに引っかからなかったらたちまち忘れる
教えてもすぐ忘れる 欲か怒りが必要です
物事を覚えるために で
真剣に覚えて 今ここのこの場で理解してください
この心理学は仏教以外聞くことはできません
これも普通の心理学 今日はあまり経典は引用
あまりではなくて 今日引用しないことにしたんです
ただの心理学の講義だと思ってください
だから 私が言っていることと世間で言っている心理学とどうですかね
全く違うことを言っていますけど
どちらが正しいと言う
言える 欲がないと物事を覚えると思う
怒りがないと物事を覚えると思う
例えば 誰かさんがね かなりかっこよく英語を喋ったとしましょう
友達が それは友達がね
自分を馬鹿にしちゃった
あんたはね それぐらいも英語も知らんでしょうねとかね
昔から頭があまり良くなかったしねとか何か言われたら腹が立つでしょ
これで腹が立って こんちくしょって気分になっちゃって
さっさと あの 何でしたっけ？スピードラーニングというね
CD を高いお金で買って
朝からバンバンってそれを聞いて
英語あれで並べません
習えませんだけど 発音ぐらいはね
もつくれると何とかなるでしょうね
やっぱり覚えられちゃいますよ
やっぱり友達にガフンと言わせたいんですよ
馬鹿にされちゃったんだから
馬鹿にされてたまるかいという
それが怒りの感情なんですよ
それで勉強するんです
あるいは逆に あの人 すごく英語を喋ってね
かっこよかったな 羨ましいなと思っちゃうと欲でしょ
で 俺もやりますということになるんです
だから心にログインすれば貪瞋痴なんです
心の中身を見ると これは存在欲なんです
生きていきたいだけなんです
はい 最後のフレーズは
覚えたものは真実ではなく
自分の存在欲を支えると思われるものになります
我々は物事を覚えて学んで
立派な知識人になるつもりはないんです
存在欲 これで生きていられますよと
これで立場つけられますよと
これで世間に後ろめたさがなくなりますよと
これなら胸を張っていられますよと
これなら会社はクビにならんぞというところなんです
命を何とか物事を覚えて安定しようとするんです
だから知識世界でもいつでも資格は取るわ取るわ取るわ
大学の先生たちも毎年毎年まあ研究
研究してレポート出して
研究してレポート出しても
誰も読まないんですけど
本人以外はね で これ金かかって印刷までして
で これで教授会に出すんですよ
今年はこれぐらいしましたよと
あれって職業安定安定するためにやっていることですよ
だから知識 知識を増やす目的はないんです
誰でも同じことですよ
すごいかっこ悪いんですよ
仏教から見れば 我々はただもうごまかしてるだけ
はい それ 前の際でありましたけど
うーんと うん はい うん
あの 自分が知ってるものは正しいと我々思ってるでしょ？あれ
ちょっと疑った方がいいんです
正しいでもどうでもいいんです
私たちにとっては これで生きていられるならば
それで十分です 例えば人々に麻薬を売るっていうことはね
若者に残酷な行為でしょ
若者の将来は全部なくなるでしょ
でも売るんちゃ売りますよ
あんたそれ悪いと思わないのかと
いえ それは買う人の責任だと
自分の身を守ること 自分の責任ですよ
俺が親じゃないないんだからと
でっかい態度取るんですよ
だから自分がやってること正しいと思ってるんです
麻薬売ることは だって自分にそれで金入るでしょ
自分がそれで生きてられるでしょ
だからそれは極端な例で
私たちもね やってることは正しいと思ってやってますよ
だから正しいかどうか
客観的な正しいかどうかどうでもいいんです
知識の場合は 歴史っていうものはほとんど嘘でしょ
作り話ですよ もうまあなすごい怪しいんですね
歴史は 私は勉強しない項目のリストで 1 になるのは歴史なんです
子供の頃から こんなのはバカが勉強すればいいんじゃないかと
どうも怪しいんですよ
で 年取ってからさらにニュースを読んだり
テレビのニュース番組聞いたり
いろんな記事を読んだりすると
今我々生きてる社会の実際の状況は表現してないんです
誰かさんの勝手で主観で
自分のバイアスで偏見を語っているだけなんですね
全然このジャーナリズムというのは今現在でもひとかけらもないんです
だったら古い歴史も信頼できる
そういうわけで でも歴史学者はいるし
歴史研究する人もいるし
歴女という方もいるしね
ガレキもこれから出るでしょうと思いますけど
いろいろまあ歴女さんはいいんだけど
ただ楽しんでるんだからね
まあ歴史をね それはそれでいいんですけど
しかし その通りでしょうかね
歴史学者は歴史を学ぶことで生計を立ててますよ
それだけ それから歴史を学び
学んだところで 学校でなんとなく気分がよくなった
あるいは難しい数学やらここら辺は楽やとかね
何かあったでしょ 気持ちが
その感情で歴史になっちゃっただけ
私は子供の頃 歴史のことをもう中学生の時
もっと前からね ちょこちょこっと教えてくれると
なんだこりゃと思っちゃったんです
だから自分の感情が起きなかったんですね
めんどくさい なんで 1200なんたらなんたらかんで
なんだら年で なんだらかんだろ起きたとか覚えなくちゃあかんかと
８世紀でこうなったとかね
それなんか歴史古いんだからね
自分の国で 紀元前6000年 6
年  600年ですね まあ書いてある歴史はね
これ書いてるんだからまた面倒くさいんですね
私はこれが怪しいと思うんですね
だから自分がそちらに興味がいかなかったんですね
だから先生たち あんた頭が悪いと色々言われるんです
では 現代的に役に立つ項目でどうですか？とその先生に聞きたくなったんですけどね
それは別な先生ですからしょうがなかったんです
悔しがったんですけど
歴史を教える先生は私が頭が悪いと決めていて
数学やら英語やら他のものを教える先生はいつでも満点取っちゃいますから
随分頭がいいと言われていて
褒めてくれたんだけどね
まあどうでもいい 過去の話ですから
歴史ですから どうでもいいんですけど
だから言いたいのは やっぱり自分のそういう気持ちがね
引き立ててくれるものは覚えておく
それは正しいかどうかどうでもいいんです
俺にとって面白い それだけの話なんです
はい 次に行きましょう
記憶は大事でしょうか？というポイントですね
生きるために 死を避けるために必要な情報を記憶しなくてはならないんですね
やっぱり記憶喪失では死んじゃいますよ
もうキャベツだと思ってね
なんか別なものを食べちゃったらどうなるんですかね
世間の知識は欲と怒りという 2つの器に入るものです
だから記憶ダメっていうことではないんです
何か覚えてないと生きていられません
しかし これ断言的にイエスとは言えないことなんですね
必要ですが 大事といったら
うーん ちょっと待ってと言わなくちゃいけないんです
理由は 2番  2行目で書いてありますね
知識っていうのは 2つの器に入るんですね
欲と怒りに 記憶がゼロなら生きていられません
渇愛は一切の生命に共通するので
すべての生命は存在とするために欠かせない情報を知っています
本当は勉強しなくても生きていられますよ
これ 勉強しなきゃ生きてられるの
たった人間だけなんですよ
生命っていうのはものすごい無双
すりあってものすごい次元があって
この中でも取りに足らない人間界だけなんですね
勉強しなきゃ困るっていうことはかわいそうですね
それでも人間の中でもいますからね
何も勉強しないのに ちゃんと堂々と生きている
なおさら悔しいでしょう
動物世界ではね 社会問題はないし
健康の問題はないし 子育ての問題はないし
政治的なトラブルはないし
まあ戦いとか争いとかあるんだけど
結構よく楽に生きています
秘密はあります 勉強していないんです
それで私が言いたいポイントは
記憶ゼロだったら生きていられません
だから犬も猫もミミズもアメーバさえも
単細胞の記憶はあるんです
だから生きているんですよ
人間には寿命を全うすることできるんだけど
動物はね 結構全うします
誰かに殺されない限りは
人間は誰かに殺されてないでしょう
殺されてないんだけど
寿命を全うすることはできないんですね
魚でももう殺して食べない限りは
見事に長生きして年取って死ぬんです
昔 私の国のお寺で 1匹のかっこ悪い魚を飼っていたことがあるんですよ
あれって何歳になったかわからない
私の子供頃からいたんですね
これ 結構大きくなりまして
そんなに普通人間食べる魚の種類なんです
で 川にいてね これずっと人間生活しているんだからね
まあ結構人間と馴染みがあって
私とは結構遊ぶんです
はっちゃんめっちゃ遊ぶ
だから私ももうすごく楽しいし
一緒に遊ぶのはね でも信じられない
もうもうただあいつがね
外へ出られないだけで
いろんなことをやってるし
だから私は水の中に手とかそうやってこぶしって出したら
あの水筒の 水筒 なんていうのは水槽の一番後ろに行って
キーっと飛んできて パチンと当たるんですよ
結構痛いんですけど 力いっぱい殴るんですね
それでまた後ろに行ってまた待ってるんです
はい もう一度やってくださいと
で 体を触ったりすると
もう楽しくて真っ赤になるんです
全部 体中すごく可愛かったんですね
ものすごい もしかすると 30年
40年ぐらい生きていたと思います
本当に普通のおじいさんのように年取って
ここら辺は骨 顎の骨とか見えるようになったりして
ある日は死んでいたんです
それはちょっと悲しかったんです
どれほど私と仲良くになったかというと
ある日 すごい雨が降っていて
あの水が入っていたあれがね
コンクリートのタンクでしたけど
そちらいっぱい水が増えていて
私はあんまりこの辺もちょこっと魚とちょっと見てもう出ていたんですね
遊べないで こいつはもう
あれ あれ あちらから飛ぶんですよ
外に びっくりしました
だから重くて また戻すことも大変で
誰にも取れないし 私でないと結構重い
これ 水槽からもう何回飛びます？飛んでたというと
私の声なんかなんとか水で何か感じたら何か感じるでしょ
爬虫類も飛びます 外に
だからこれまで人間馴染んでいたんだから
悲しくなるのはなりますからね
では何が言いたいかというと
動物は寿命を全うする
人間だけですね 違うところは人間が勉強するんですよ
やめた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
なんかそれは冗談ですけどまあ
しかし この動物も覚えてはいる
あの魚さんも私とはすごく仲良く仲良しですけど
お寺にちっちゃなガキたちが来ると逆の態度取るんです
攻撃するんで怖がらせるんです
そばに寄ろうとするといきなり飛んじゃって
みんなもう体中見する
だから子供たちは逃げる
だからいたずらするっていうことを知ってるでしょうし
私がそばに座ったらそんなことはないんですね
とにかく自分の体を私の体につけようとしているだけで
だから覚えてるんですね
だからアメーバにしたっても
どうやって まあ命短いかもしれませんだけど
生きていられますかね
何か知らないと 命を守ることと
命を危険にさらされるものは何かと知っておかないと生きていられませんね
ですから 生きるために必要なデータは
我々にとっては本能として
この無明と渇愛が一応入れてあります
あのパソコン買う時は基本プログラムぐらいを入れてあるでしょ
そんな感じで 一応プリインストールはしています
必要なものは 渇愛と まあそこはありました
記憶する情報は概念に限ってないんです
皆様 それは私の言葉 怪しいなと思うかもしれませんね
アメーバ記憶あるんだと言ったら笑っちゃうでしょ
笑わないね もっとそんなにバカバカらしい話ですかね
記憶ありますよ これ 我々がこの脳細胞があって
脳の中でなんだらかんだらな臓器があって
そちらにデータ記録するんだという
あんな勘違いだから この勘違いが起こるんです
こんな脳細胞なくたっても生命は生命です
だから概念だけではないんです
概念も記憶ですけど リンゴとかね
卵とかね キュウリとかね
それも概念ですけど 我々はキュウリといったら緑色で細長くて
なんか凸凹があったりしてね
まあそんなものですけど
あれ虫も食べてるでしょうに
虫にとっては長さとか全然関係ないでしょ
だからキュウリを食べる虫にとっては
キュウリとキュウリの葉っぱ同じ色でしょ
でもこれは葉っぱで これは茎でちゃんとわかってます
だけど それは学校に行ってないんだから
生まれる時のプリインストールした記憶なんです
はい 次回の感情の分化
無明とか諸は分化するので 1500煩悩になってしまいます
だからこれ細胞分化の言葉借りましたけど
あの 今日はあの ちゃんと調べたんです
分化の意味はね ディファレンシエーションというね
で 調べたらもうすごい苦しかったんですね
いろんな分野で使いますね
この言葉は ディファレンシエーションという英単語はね
バイオロジーの場合は
基本的な細胞はある別々
特定の仕事をするために変わることなんですね
分化って 例えば骨の細胞
心臓の細胞とかね 皮膚の細胞とかに分化していくんですね
だから仏教にもいい単語なんです
分化は 基本的に我々の心が無明と渇愛なんですよ
それだけではちょっと困ります
それで分化するんです
1500に 感情という器の中に記憶するデータが保存されます
ですから 貪瞋痴でも器は 3つでしょ
だから器は 2つにしか物事は入りませんね
これで困ります だから 1500程度に分化するんです
そうすると結構データ入ります
それによって人間の場合は知るべきもの
知ってはならないもの
役に立つもの 役に立たないもの
関係があるもの 関係がないものなど
様々なデータが覚えておくんです
これは人間の問題なんです
何を勉強しているかって
俺 役に立つか立たないか
関係あるかないか どうでもいい
いろんなこと学ぶんですよ
宇宙の星を数える人もいるし
もう大根で植えたらいいのに
博士号まで取って もう億単位で金無駄遣いして星空を欲しがっているんです
だからそこは普通できないはずなんです
そんなくだらないことは
貪瞋痴だけだったらできません
あれ あの望遠鏡でね 同じ位置に合わせて
もう無双に毎日毎日写真撮って撮って撮って撮って
比較して 微妙な変化をチェックして計算するんです
それでなんだらかんだら星を見つけたとかね
こんなスピードで移動しているんだとかね
やっぱり私は大根育てた方がいいと思いますけど
この感情がね 分化しちゃったんだから
あれ面白くできます はい
次 感情の暴走 これで私が言ってるポイントは
我々は学んで知識を得て覚えちゃいますけど
結局がこれ生きるためにやっているもので
敵を倒すためにやっているもので
だからこれは事実かどうかどうでもいいんです
それで科学者の顔をするなよと私が言いたいんです
特に仏教は世界でかなり馬鹿にされているでしょ
最近 この自分も感情で覚えちゃってね
あるあるテレビ番組でこの北野武さん
ビートたけしさんがいて
結構才能ある人だからね
で いろいろ面白いことを言うんですよ
この人に悪口言いたくないんですけど
何かいろんなもうくだらんことを書いている人だって
実はこの まあクリスマスについて
いろいろ一見まあうちは仏教だからクリスマスやらないバカもバカもいるんだよとか
なんとかそういう行があったんですね
言ったらこの若者のアナウンサーの人が番組持っている人なので
そんな人は今更いないでしょうにと言うんですね
日本人でクリスマスやらない人はと
いませんよ と言ったら
たけしさんが負けませんだから
なんのこと？うちの親父そうでしたからと
笑 俺は仏教徒だから決して
決してクリスマスやりませんよと
私が気にかかったのは
あの若者の態度なんですね
クリスマスやらないことはダサい
時代遅れ という気持ちは腹が立っちゃったんで
お前でしょうにと 間抜けが
俺はひとつやりましょうと言ったら
胸入っちゃえばいいでしょう
だからそういう風にちょっとこのだからテレビ見るんで全部忘れるんだけど
なんでそれを覚えちゃったというと
やっぱり気持ちで引っかかったでしょ
引っかかったんだ 腹が立ったんだから
それを覚えちゃったんです
はい それで感情といういい加減なものの上に気づく知識なんですね
記憶ですね 感情が暴走するんですね
これは知識にも記憶にも影響を与えます
感情には理論何もないんです
これが暴走すると 記憶が大変なことになります
例えば 怒りの気持ちが暴走しちゃうと
怒りによってつけた知識
どうなるんですかね 記憶が
激しく動き回るんです
欲だったら これ千五百ですからね
千五百といってもちょっと例を出さない
例えば嫉妬 落ち込み 後悔
舞い上がる 他人を見下す
そういうふうに千五百になるんです
自分をもう現実より高く見せる
膨らまして自分を世間に見せるとかね
そういうふうに貪瞋痴が千五百に分けてしまいますよ
だからそれによって覚えちゃうんです
例えば 自分をちょっと膨らまして見せたこと
見せたいという気分があると勉強するでしょ
なんか覚えておきます
はい そういうことで そのその感情が暴走すると
覚えておいた概念も暴走する羽目になるんです
激しく揺られるんですよ
まあもう日本はね まあプレートの上にありますから
複数の断層の上にありますから
上に建てる建物はね プレートが動くと
俺は動きませんよとはダメでしょう
断層が動いたってもね
俺は知ったことないぞと
まあダメでしょ 建物も揺れて壊れる
海から津波が来る 道路が 2つに割れちゃう
橋が割れて落ちるわ   だからそれって楽しい？じゃないでしょ
とてつもない危険なことなんです
感情がもともと悪いものだから
その上に作った概念 記憶は
まあ悪いとはちょっと言いづらいんだけど
あんまりいいものじゃないんですね
これ暴走すると大変です
ある感情が強くなったとき
それに関連する物事をいたずら簡単に覚えたり
普通に覚える必要があるものを覚えられなくなったり
覚えたものが心から削除されたり
覚えたデータが混乱してありもしない変なものになったりします
また こういうことが起きるんです
で 感情の暴走についていくつかのランクで
これ  1時間  2時間でしゃべれませんよ
これは膨大な量ですからね
ごまかすしかないんですけど
で 次に言いたいところは
例えば私の心ですっごく怒りが現れてきたら
この怒りに応援するものは一発で覚えちゃうんです
例えば 私がB さんについて機嫌が悪くなっている
もう怒ってるんですね
それで誰かさんが来て
何年何月何日 何曜日 何時で
この人はね 何々さんに何とか場所でこういうようなことを言いましたと言ったら
バチッと覚えちゃうんです
あ そうか 忘れませんね
普段ものすごく頭悪いくせに
我々みんなそうなんですよ
だから千五百の煩悩の中で
その時ちょっと強くなっている感情に合わせて合わせるデータが入っちゃうんです
それで 例えば授業中だとしましょう
真剣に勉強しなくちゃいかんですよ
そこで自分には怒りが込み上がっているんですね
そうすると 隣に授業を聞いている生徒さんが
あのね あんた知ってますかね？先生は私の家の隣ですからね
昨日奥さんにぶん殴られたんだよと
それぴちっと覚えちゃうんです
授業は聞いてないんです
あ そうかそうか 今度言ってやるぞとか
そういう性格ですね だから
まあもう我々の心ってそんなもんなんですよ
それで感情が出てくると
覚えてはならないものは覚えなかったり
覚えられなかったり 覚えたあかんものは覚えたり
大事なデータ忘れたり
削除されたり 頭から綺麗さっぱり削除する場合もあります
この千五百感情の中でも
あのこの相性が悪いものがあるんですよ
同時に生まれない それで相性が悪い感情がどんどん現れてくると
前起きた記憶したデータにはいる場がない
いなくなっちゃうんですね
その感情の器がなくなるんだからね
で 削除されますよ それからとんでもないことをするんです
我々はこの過去の記憶したデータを
感情が現れるたびに再び合成するんです
自分好みで 時々何かデータ知ったんだけど
1年  2年経って喋ると
とんでもないあり得もしないことを喋っているんです
これは脳科学的にも同じことを言っています
人間の目目撃証拠っていうのは全然アテにならんと
目撃したっても目撃してないんです
自分の気分次第でいい加減適当でデータ取って適当にストーリー作るんです
それだけ はい 次 どのように覚えるのでしょうか？という覚える方法
存在に欠かせないものは自動的に覚えてしまいます
苦労しなくてもいいんです
皆さん方 火の遊びしないでしょ
赤信号はね 間違ってでも渡らないでしょ
まあそういう人もいますからね
しょうがない  まあ私たちはそんなに
苦労しなくても 例えば何も教えなくても
人間は大きな動物は怖いんです
クマにやられたことは一度もないんだけど
クマはクマは怖いでしょ
皆様にも皆様の先祖を七代
八代 八代まで遡ってみても
蛇は迷惑をかけたことはないんです
が 蛇のことを嫌いでしょ
だからこんなのはなんで覚えてるんですかね
あれは基本データです
自動的に覚えてるんです
また そのデータは忘れることもありません
皆様はね まあ周り 下の知り合いの人々に親しく親しく優しくされたことはきれいさっぱり忘れちゃいますけど
こういう基本的なデータは決して忘れません
蛇は怖いということを忘れません
生存に間接 間接的に必要なものを努力して覚えなくてはいけないんです
そこで この直接生存に関係あるものはオートモードで覚えています
で 間接的に関係あるものは頑張って覚えるんです
例えば 数学なんかは命に何の関係もないでしょう
でも間接的に役に立ちますね
だから苦労して覚えるんです
学校で学ぶものは 生きるためには何の役にも立ちません
しかし 学校で学んだ知識は間接的に役に立ちます
仕事を見つかれるし 仕事できるようになっているし
文章は読めるし 書けるし
これで給料をもらってご飯食べられます
だから間接的だから苦労するんです
本当は勉強したくないんです
修復しない場合は場合と必要がなくなる場合
その記憶はなくなります
そこでこの無理をして間接的に関係あるものを覚えても
修復する必要ある 復習する必要あるんです
でなきゃ忘れる あるいは役に立たなくなったら忘れます
私は ３０何年前 日本に来た時はペラペラドイツ語もフランス語も喋れたんですよ
日本に来て その日から使えなくなっちゃったんです
今 きれいさっぱり脳から削除されているんです
きれいさっぱり何もないんです
全くわからない そんなもんです
激しい欲 恐怖 怒りなどの感情を引き起こした出来事も長期記憶になるのです
忘れられません そこで我々は忘れられない記憶っていうのは基本データ
それはまあパソコン買うと同じで
生まれると付いてるんです
間接的データは役に立つ場合は OK です
役に立たなくなると削除されます
それからもう一つあります
激しい欲が湧いてきたならば
頭が狂っちゃうほど欲が湧いてきたら
そのデータは忘れられません
このかつてよかったとかね
その時のあの人の顔も今のように覚えていますよとかね
あるでしょ もう写真記録していますね
この恐怖と怒りってのは同じものなんですよ
人にぶつかると 人に嫌な気分
ぶつかると怒りと言うんです
同じ感情 自分の中に入ると恐怖なんです
恐怖感で悩まされている方々は
あれ 怒りで悩んでいるんです
ただ 怒りは人にぶつけてないんです
だから自分に 内向きになっています
そうなると恐怖 いても立ってもいられない状態
泣いたりもします はい
これでこんな感じで覚えているんです
あまりにもこれもかっこよくないんですよ
いやいやで勉強するでしょうに
これも復習しないと忘れちゃう
仕事上で覚えたものは使っている場合はうまくいきますけどもね
学んだものは仕事に役に立たなくなっちゃうと全部忘れてしまうという
落ちます 残念なことに
この危険な激しい感情が引き起こしたものは
また長期記憶になっちゃいます
それも忘れられません
はい 次の記憶は期間限定です
一般に言えば 存在とは肉体の維持です
一般的に言えば これ仏教的じゃなくて
普通の人々は生きていきたいということは大したことなくて
肉体を維持したいだけなんです
この肉体を維持したい
従って 記憶は肉体の状況によって変わるんです
肉体を媒介して覚えるんです
肉体のために覚えるんです
だったら肉体は変化すると
覚えたものも時間限定で消えてしまいます
だから若いんだから ギターを弾いたり
バンドを組んで遊んだりするでしょ
激しく踊ることもできるし
あれ 肉体限定なんです
これで中年になってくると
腰が重くて 足が硬くて
もう踊れないんですね
もう指が遅くて ギターはちょっとできないんですね
さっさっさっと動かないんです
昔はドラムやっていたかもしれませんだけど
こんなにスピーディーに両足も両手も動きもなくなっちゃうんですね
それでどうなるかというと
あの記憶がどんどんどんどん消されていきます
死で全ての記憶は消されます
もったいないね すごい金かけて学んだのに
だって世界一流の天才の知識人見るでしょ
死ぬまでです 人に過去世は思い出せないんです
過去があったんですよ
元の何も思い出せませんね
すべて消されています
肉体に限定です しかし
無明 渇愛 貪瞋痴などに記憶によって起こる影響は長きにわたって残ります
悪いことばっかしなんですよ
で 学ぶと覚えると 貪瞋痴が影響を受けます
刺激を受けます この影響は残るんです
だから 生まれたばっかしの赤ちゃんたち調べると
怒りっぽい赤ちゃんがいるわ
よっぽどのことに泣かない赤ちゃんがいるわ
何やっても気が済まない赤ちゃんがいるわ
いろいろでしょう よく微笑んでる赤ちゃんがいるわ
なかなか寝ない 寝るのは怖がってる赤ちゃんもいるわ
起きてほしいなのに起きてこない
おっぱい吸いながらまた半分もう吸ってないくせに寝ている
ややこしい連中もいますよ
だから赤ちゃんお腹いっぱいおっぱい飲まなくちゃあかんでしょ
もうギャーギャーと泣いておっぱい吸い始めるんだけど
まだお腹いっぱいになってないんで
もう寝ているんです そういう赤ちゃんもいるんです
そこで またおっぱいを吸ってお腹がいっぱいになったら
乳首を離れません 離せません
これ噛むんですね そういう赤ちゃんもいます
一番お母さんが困るのは
この歯が 2本だけできている時
下はないんだけどね あれで噛むんですね
乳首は あります その赤ちゃんの性格
本人がふざけて遊んでいるんです
お腹いっぱいになるまで丁寧に吸うんです
いっぱいになったら お母さん知らないんだからまだ吸ってるだろうと思っているのではなくて
あれ 噛んで なんか痛くさせたいんですね
だから なんで生まれつきそういう風に来るんですかね
あれは過去の記憶が感情に影響を与えたんです
それは残るんです 永久的じゃなくて
長きにわたって残るんです
これは俗世間で人格と言うんですね
パーソナリティと言うんですね
瞑想修行によって 心が体に依存することを一時的にストップすることで
認識次元を超えられます
だから我々は肉体のために勉強しています
肉体が腐っていくと 勉強も同時に腐っていくんです
もっとマジなことを勉強できないのかといったら
やっぱり瞑想実践が必要になるんですね
瞑想実践して この感情が肉体に依存しているんだから
これカットするんです
それで心には次元を超えた知識
データ 知ることはできます
一般人間には全く知ることは不可能な
どんな顕微鏡でも どんな望遠鏡でも
知ることは不可能なデータまでも知り得ます
では皆様 怖がることを言います
例えば 肉体との関係 一時的にカットしておくと
例えば人間が頭の中でペラペラペラペラ喋ってるでしょ
同じ声で聞こえるようになるんです
それは嫌でしょうね 一般の人にはできませんよ
それはまあ 慈しみのある心添えた人々に聞こうと思えば聞こえるんです
思えばなんです 大抵思わない
相当うるさいですからね
まあとにかく次元を超えた知識を得たければ
まあ瞑想して肉体との関係をカットしなくちゃあかんのです
記憶は曖昧 確実ではない
感情 煩悩によって物事を記憶するので
覚えの質は人によって変わります
覚えの量よりも質です
人によって変わります
それからも感情の波によって覚えが変質され
書き換え 元と全く違うものになったりもします
で 覚えておいたっても
あんまり当てにならない
これは書き換えたり編集したりします
感情で それから私が覚えているものと
あの人が覚えているものは結構違いますね
感情によって時々もう悪いものばっかり覚える人もいるでしょ
不正はどう働かすのかとかね
法律はどうやってくぐるのかとかね
どうやって人を騙せるのかと
そんな悪知恵ばっかり
好きでたまらない人もいるし
そんなこと気持ち悪いという人もいるし
だから質はね 感情が決めます
記憶の 我々の脳が入るデータを必ず自分勝手に編集して現象化して残すんです
脳から説明すると 脳は全然ありのままに知らないんです
勝手に何か作るんです
いつでも 音が入ったとたん
何かイメージ作るんです
勝手なんです 音を聞かないんです
音を入るとサーッと工場妄想工場を始めて
ねつ造するんです いろんな概念作っちゃうんです
そこでそれを記憶するんです
とんでもないやつなんですよ
感情の変化によって元の覚えが完全消えたりもします
記憶にはファイナルリポートはありません
だから記憶っていうのはいつでも曖昧で中途半端で確実じゃないんです
記憶にはファイナルリポートというものはあり得ません
はい 次 思い出すというテーマに入ります
なんか飛ばさないと 今日なんかやばい １
勝手に記憶がよみがえる ２
意図的に思い出す ３ 状況に応じて必要なデータが現れる
という３種類あるんです
私は自慢げに考えたんですけど
これは大学でやったならば
1 年間の授業料容量なんです
はい １の説明に入ります １
感情の荒波です 貪瞋痴が暴走しています １
っていうのは勝手に思いよみがえる記憶が
あれ やばい ただ過去のことをよみがえってくる
全然何もしていないんですよ
すごい危険です なぜかというと
感情が荒波を起こしているんです
だから時々もう もう今八十
七十歳ですけど 二十歳のことを思い出したり
よみがえったりとか 私は昔見たことがありますね
もうある酔っ払いがね
突然怒り出して 誰かさんにものすごく怒鳴りつけるんですね
で 周りは私もいたんだけど
誰のことかよくわからないんですね
あいつはこんなことをして私を騙しやがって
ただすみませんとか どんどんって何か包丁でもて殺しに行っちゃったんですね
そう 殺してやらなくちゃいけないと
それで周りがこの同じ年の人々やらとかね
どういうことかといったら
なんかみんななんかこうね
見つけたんですね もうはちゃで程度ぐらいの誰かと喧嘩し
もう 60歳の 40歳かなの人なんです
だからその殺しに行った人はその田舎にいないんです
どこにいるか誰もわからないんです
で この人がまあまああいつを殺してやらなくちゃって殺しに行ってるんです
酔っ払っちゃって だから酔ったらどうなるかというと
感情が荒波を起こすんですね
だから理性は遮断するんだから
一番人間にとっては一番危険な状態に陥るんです
それで何年前のことでも
目の前で蘇ってくるんです
取りとめようのない妄想の回転になります
精神的に病気になってしまいます
煩悩が許可して頑丈に固定されます
だから これ 仏教から見れば一番困ることなんです
記憶が勝手に蘇ること
煩悩が頑強になるんです
人格向上を目指す人にとっては最大の障害なんです
この3種類の 1 記憶 思い出す場合は 1 勝手に蘇る
はい  2 にいきます 意図的に思い出す
これはわかりやすい 勉強するときは強引に覚えなくてはならないでしょ
試験では強引に意図的に記憶を蘇らなくちゃいかんですね
嫌で嫌で思い出さなくちゃあかんです
これ 2番目なんです 仕事をするとき
研究するとき 講演するとき
起こさなくてはいけない出来事
ん？なんかおかしい そうでしょうと思いますね
まあ今忘れてください
時々止めてください で
その時も記憶を 思い出さなくちゃあかんですね
2番目なんです 今も私は 2番目やっているんです
しかし これも感情が割り込むとうまくいかないんですよ
例えば試験中ですけど
緊張がしちゃったと 怖くなっちゃったら終わりでしょ
半年も練習したせて 発表会ですけど
緊張したって膝が震え出したらどうなる？終わり
もう出てこない メモを書いたり
先に練習したりする必要もありますね
で 結構人々はメモを書いたりするんですね
講演する方々は結構メモをするんですね
有名な人々は あの 極限怠け者たちで
知識人にスクリプト書いてもらうんですよ
アメリカの大統領やらローマ法王というおじいさんとかね
で ちゃんとスクリプト書いてもらって
また直して直して直してもらって
また二 三回読み上げてみて
で どこで？特にアメリカの場合はね
どこでストップするのかとか
みんなスタンディングオベーションしなくちゃあかんだからね
これ決まってみんなやらせでやってるんですよ
テレビ見てください それでみんな拍手をしてすごい時間取るんです
それから丁寧に座るんですね
それでまたオバマさんが次のフレーズを始めるんですね
よう恥ずかしくないんですね
あの連中は だから これ
必要な時 必要なデータを出さなくちゃあかんでしょ
その能力ないんですよ
だからオバマさんの話は
ノーベルの文学賞を取っている人々が書いている
それまた何回も書き換えて書き直して
時間範囲に合わせる よりも
みんなに大騒ぎ バカ騒ぎする時間も必要ですからね
それも入れて それからいくらかリピートして喋るんですね
スクリプト読み上げる
なぜかというと このローマ法王が説法する時でも
やっぱり世界に向けて喋るんだから
世界の現代人間に必要なことを言わなくちゃいけない
その自信がないんです
言ったらみんなに批判されることばっかりなんです
現代の法王は 前の人はかなりね
気持ちの優しいおじいさんでしたからね
なんか変なこと言ったって
みんななんかニコッと笑って聞いてるだけだったけど
だから そういう偉い方々はちゃんと書いて読み上げる
私が文句言いたいのは
文章を読み上げるんだったら
プロのアナウンサー頼んだらどうですか？と
アナウンサーっていうのは読み上げる仕事でしょ
どうでもいいんです さん状況に応じて必要なデータが現れる
3番目 人に出会ったら
その人と交わした約束を思い出します
もうちょっと遅いんですけどね
何か約束はしたんだけど
忘れちゃって またその人に会ったら
あっ そんな時思い出しちゃうんですね
そういう風に状況に応じて思い出すことはあります
私はわざと悪い例を出しただけで
あの 悪い例ばっかりじゃないんですよ
例えばね まあえっと 誰かのね
どういうと 何て言いますか
誰かに受験勉強ね 勉強教えて教えている先生がいるとしますね
それで先生の家に生徒が入ってくると
あっと思い出すでしょ
あの子の勉強の時間だと
で 先生はもしかすると料理を作っていたかもしれません
で ピンポンって言ったら
自分の家に来て勉強する子供で
コメントあっ 勉強で じゃあちょっとそれで待ってくださいと言って
そっちの方に行くんですね
それで勉強のことだけ全部思い出すんですね
そういう風に日常起こることで
それは外国人に出会ったら覚えた外国語を思い出すとかね
で 弁護士が趣味で料理をするとしましょう
料理の仲間といるとき
料理知識を思い出すんですね
仕事場では法律に関わることを思い出すんです
だから 必要に応じて思い出すんです
この能力はお釈迦様が推薦されています
お釈迦様がすごく推薦するのはその能力なんです
必要な時 必要なデータを思い出せと
後で思い出したって意味がないんだと
あ 言い忘れちゃったとかね
あ 悔しいとかね 人生の人生をトラブルなく過ごすためには必要な能力です
これが で これ早くやって
やってみます 忘れるとは
特別な項目にします 忘れるということはチャプターにします
あの 流砂に飲まれないために
流砂でしたっけ はい 忘れることはできますかね
まあもう説明しましたからね
忘れることは残念ながら自動的に起こるんです
覚えておくべきことを忘れて
忘れるべきことばかり心に刻まれます
これが現実です 意図的に何かの訓練をして覚えたことを忘れることは不可能です
それ 方法はありません
忘れられる 忘れさせる方法はないんです
これは自動です 勝手に
忘れちゃいます だから管理できない
忘れちゃったものは必要なものだったら
だから誠に我々人間どもは残念な状況にいるんです
だから不可能ですけど
世の中には詐欺師がいますよ
そのために暗示を使ったり
洗脳したりなどのやましいことまでします
忘れるために人に暗示かけて
あなたはこれからこれはきれいさっぱり忘れますよとかね
こんな一匹ですよ こんなことで忘れられません
ただ 脳の脳をいじっているだけ
それで洗脳するでしょ
洗脳しちゃうと脳機能低下するんですよ
だから思い出せなくなっちゃう
洗脳されたことばっかしで
洗脳的になってしまいます
こんなのはやましいことです
やってはいけないことです
覚えたデータをあえて忘れる必要はありません
だから今日のテーマではね
どうやって悪いことを忘れますかという期待あっただろうと思いますけど
私の答えは忘れなくてもいいんです
無理 こんなのは  そのうち忘れるかもしれませんし
忘れられないかもしれません
だっているんだから 結婚して 30年ですけど
まだ初恋の人を忘れられない
これで年取ったおばあちゃんにもし突然出会ったら
あの若い時のあれよみがえってきて
奥さんを捨てられるとかね
あるんだからもうどうしようもないんですよ
でも フラレふ人をフラれ
まあフラれてもう 3日も経ってないのに
もう忘れている人もいますよ
誰かの女性にフラれちゃったんですけど
もう次の日にまた別の人とまた仲良くしていると
まあ忘れたかっていうことじゃないんですよ
やっぱり これはもう人間に管理できないんです
無理です だから まあ忘れられないものは忘れられないものでいいんです
だったらどうすればいいかと
これ答えなんで これ気をつけて読んでください
感情とのコネを切るんです
貪瞋痴の感情がデータを覚えさせる
それもありのままではなく
勝手なストーリーに合わせて合わせてです
感情の暴走によって 記憶がいつでも新たなバージョンを作って現れる
蘇る場合もある だから記憶というのはそんなもんで
いつでも変化 変容する
人は記憶を忘れるのではなく
悪感情を制御した方が正しいんです
データはデータで置いておいて
感情との縁を切っちゃうんです
災害に遭った人は災害を忘れるのではなく
恐怖感 悲しみ 落ち込みを忘れるんです
これはできます 感情だから
だから気分を直すんです
データを忘れるんじゃないんです
ああ そんなこともあったねとかね
そうすると鮮明に覚えられますよ
例えば津波に流されて命拾いしたら
恐怖感でいると何も思い出せない
思い出せる ただ恐怖感だけでではなくて
恐怖感って感情ですから
気分変えれば感情が変わりますからね
例えば毎日 3時間くらいロック音楽でも歌って踊っちゃえば
もう変わりますよ 大したことないんです
で 気持ちが恐怖感を忘れたところで
鮮明にこんな風に水が上がった
その時 私はこれにぶつけた
こうなった ああなったとかね
リポートすることさえもできます
そこで口に塩が入っちゃって
まあもうこんな感じでしたよとかね
これで息をしようとして顔を上げたら油だらけでしたよとかね
それで隣に火がついていたんだから
またやばいと思って またもう泳いでね
いろんなこと言えるんですよ
そういう風に面白くレポートできるのは
感情と縁切った時なんです
これでまたよみがえると
気持ちがもうダメですね
だから記憶を忘れるものではなくて
感情との縁を切るんです
感情とのコネを切ることができれば
覚えたデータは何の問題も起こさないんです
かえって客観的に明晰に覚えていくことができます
記憶をなくすことは不可能です
都合の良いものを覚えて
都合の悪いものを忘れるなんかは成り立ちません
記憶されたデータと感情のコネを切ったところで
心が自由に安らぎになるんです
はい これでちょっと10分休憩いたします
はい 次 記憶術ということで
記憶に対する倫理 今まで記憶っていうのは感情ということを言ってきたんだからね
記憶は基本的に悪不全なんですね
だって貪瞋痴で記憶するんだからね
存在するために貪瞋痴が捏造したデータを心に刻むんです
まず記憶は悪だとしなくてはいけません
頭で覚えているものは
まあ善か悪かといえば
悪の方に 悪というか 単語は仏教的じゃないんだけど
不善という単語ですけどね
そこで選別します 我々は選別するんです
生きるために欠かせ欠かせない知識
生きることを支える知識
生きることの障害になる知識
プラスアルファの知識
どうでもよい知識 この順番が大事なんです
記憶術ってっていうのは
そういうことから始まるんです
何でも覚えるんじゃないんです
順番に覚えておいてください
例えば 生きるために欠かせない知識はもう文句言えないでしょう
学ばなくちゃあかんですね
支える知識も必要でしょうに
そんなことを覚えてほしいんです
生きることの障害になる知識は
この中で 2種類あります
絶対勉強してはいけないものと勉強しておくもの
その中に 2つありますけどね
だから絶対勉強してはいけ
例えばピストルで撃つ練習するとかね
何のため？そんなのはやる必要はないんですね
しかし まあ地震が来たらどうしようかとかね
火事になったらどうしようかとかね
それは前もって訓練しておいた方がいいんじゃないんですかね
プラスアルファを皆様知ってるでしょ
ちょこちょこいて またどうでもいいことばっかり覚えているんだからね
それはあんまりもったいないんです
次に物事を覚えたければ目的を確定する
なんとなく学ぶ人は役に立たない愚か者で終わります
これ なんとなく勉強する人っていうのは愚か者で人生終わるんです
何のために学ぶのかと目的を設定すれば
脳は物事を楽に覚えておくんです
脳にこの目的を作ってあげてください
そうすると脳が動く 動いてくれます
この目的で勉強しましょうと
そうすると脳が落ち着くんです
わかりました そこまででしょうと
有意義か否かと関係なく
脳には有意義という保証が必要です
次に これは有意義であると自己暗示でもかけておかないと
あの脳にはどうでもいいんです
脳が あ この人は今学んでいるものは有意義で有意義だと知ったら
全部覚えておくんです
だから 何か記憶したければ
このデータが有意義であると頭に教えてあげてください
簡単に覚えてくれます
理性のある人に聞いて
真理を学んで 文字通りの有意義を発見すると
だから私は有意義  2つ教えているんです
有意義だと思っているもの
それは有意義かもしれませんし
無意味かもしれませんよ
2番目は本当に有意義なもの
それは誰かに教えてもらってください
理性のある人に 私はどんなどうすればよろしいか
どんな人間になればよろしいか
何を学べばよろしいでしょうかとか
真理を知っている人から学んでみてください
学んで言う あ これは学びます
これは有意義だとはっきり脳にインプットします
学ぶことも記憶も善になります
この最後に書いたものは
本格的な有意義なものを学ぶと
その記憶は善です 他は善でないんです
それで若者はギターの練習をするのは
これは有意義だと思っているんですよ
仲間で楽しんで遊べますよと
でも それが本当の有意義なことじゃありませんね
だから善ではないんです
真理は何かと学びましょうよと
これこそ有意義だと思ったら
その記憶はすべて善になるんです
はい これで目的を確定する
有意義ということは入れておく
それから感情の制御 欲
欲 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨み
競争心 高慢 見栄などの感情で物事を覚えられます
しかし その覚えが自分の他人の役に立つか否かは問題です
欲があったら覚えられますけど
自分の役に立つか 人の役に立つか
よくわからないんですね
ただ 以上の同じ感情は反対のデータを遮断する
だから欲で勉強すると必要なデータを遮断する可能性はあります
だから怒りで勉強すると
もう怒りに必要なものだけ
例えば皆様方はやってないでしょうね
もうクリスマスだからね
鶏を1匹丸 一羽を丸焼きにするとかね
それで欲でしょ？自分がもう
一羽丸ごとプライドチキンにして食いたいんだけど
プライドチキンって言わないんですね
日本語のプライドは違いますからね
一応 自分の立場しか考えてないんですね
これ 生命殺してるんですよ
鶏の命とか全部遮断するんです
あ この鶏がいいんだと
これでもうもう締めてもうきれいにして下さいと頼むだけ
冷蔵庫あまりない国々では生で動物売ってるでしょ
ベトナムとかね もう香港
上海でも同じことでしょ
で いろんなところでも自転車に鶏いっぱい
だからあの人々はチキン食べたいだけ
それで買っちゃいますね
そのまま鶏を秤に入れて測って売っちゃいます
だから美味しいんだ 肉だとしか見えてないんですね
これ命だと この鶏にも怯えがあるんだと
死にたくないというセクションはもう遮断
そのように我々は感情で学ぶときは
必ず大量のデータを遮断するんです
選挙運動をやっている場合は
各党が自分のいいところばっかりしゃべって
他党の悪いことばっかり言うんですね
これおかしい 理性の世界なら
それで自分の悪いところもいいようにしゃべるんです
例えば日本を取り戻すと
なんだあのフレーズはと
強盗ですかね でもいいように使っちゃうんですね
よくないんでしょうに
裏読めないんですね 民主主義の国でそんなキャッチフレーズ使うなよと
どうしても言いたければ
もっと日本を国民に返すとか
私ならキャッチフレーズ変えてあげますよ
金くれないんだからやれません
もっといいフレーズに
で この感情で勉強すると
大量に必要なデータを遮断する
で 客観的な比較評価を否定する
よくあるでしょ？批判されるとえらい気分が悪くなる
私も日本中いろんなところからいろんなことを言われてるでしょ
へっちゃらなんですけどね
全然この調子は変えません
で やっぱり理性がなく
欲で怒り 嫉妬でやっちゃうと
批判するとすごく腹が立つんですね
だから比較しないんですね
知識を捏造する 感情で勉強すると知識を捏造するんです
知識じゃないんです 真で事実を知ることと反対の態度ですね
だから感情で勉強しないでくれと言いたいんです
感情で勉強できます が
やめてくださいと なぜならば
あんた勉強していないんだ
データを捏造して捏造しているんだと
あなた批判されると腹が立つんだよと
あんた自分知ってることは
他の人知ってることと比較しないのだと
だからやめなさいとと言いたい
これは仏教の立場なんです
汚れた感情を清らかな感情で置き換えればよろしいんです
だから 汚れた感情の代わりに清らかな感情を置き換えちゃえばいいでしょう
どうせ記録は感情に記録するんだからね
しかし 清らかな感情は理解できない概念ですね
人間には 清らかな感情って何やとね
わからないんですね 仏教は無理にでも慈悲喜捨を実践しなさいと言うんです
清らかな感情に馴染めます
だから慈悲喜捨をやってください
清らかな感情は起こります
これから勉強してください
素晴らしい勉強に勉強ができるようになります
ものすごく簡単に覚えられます
慈悲のを実践すれば それで心は汚れません
それから理性と客観性を推薦します
お釈迦様は理性と客観性推薦します
理性は感情の反対なんです
理性で学べと 感情ではなくて
入るデータを一時記録して記憶して
内容を調べる 分析する
理解する 有意義か否かを決める
これは仏教的な学び方なんですね
まず覚えておく まず聞いてます
聞いてから一時記録します
一時記録して あの人は何言ったんですかね
どんな意味でしょうかねとか分析して
理解して この知識有意義か否かと判断する
それで自動的に長期記憶になっているんです
あの人言ったこと本当に役に立ちますよと思った瞬間でも覚えているんです
面白いんですよ 脳は 人の話の内容はなんとなく覚えちゃったんですけど
すぐ忘れちゃうんだけど
あのテンポラリーメモリーって一時記憶の中にある時はさっさとこれ理解するんです
理解して有意義か無意味かと判断するんです
有意義だと判断した時点で長期記憶に入ってるんです
勝手に行くんです だから無理をしなくても覚えられているんです
ずっとメモを暗記する必要ないんですよ
1発でパッパッパッと覚えられます
この裏技があるんです
今日 仏教は誰にも教えてない裏技なんで
これは 今日 皆様に一応教えてあげました
1発で覚える技 まず感情を清らかにする
それにはもう我々は子供の頃やっていたんだから良かったんですけど
皆様は無理にでも慈悲の瞑想をしてください
それから学ぶとき いつでも理屈で
理論で学んでください
理性で それからこんな話くだらん
こんな話役に立つと分けてください
これが役に立つと覚えたら
思ったらもう記憶 話終わり
記憶に必要なもの  1 有意義か否かを決めること ９
つありますよ  2 脳が面白いと感じること
3 学ぶことで脳が楽しみを感じること
脳ってえらいわがままなんですよ
楽しくなきゃやらないんです
4 探求心  5 無知は惨めだというプライド
アホは嫌やというプライドが必要です
日本みたいにアホ自慢するんじゃないんです
しっかりした理論性 論理性
いつでも論理的に物事を考えて
子供にしつけするときでも
こうだからこういう結果になるし
こうなったらこの結果になるし
ですからこうした方がいいんじゃないかと
いつでも論理で語ってください
自分も論理で考えてください
それで簡単に覚えられます
7 物事の順番を決めるストーリーがあること
覚えるときはストーリーが必要なんです
このストーリーとは論理であり
物事の順番なんです だから何かしらストーリー作っちゃえばいいんです
ない場合は自分で作るんです
何か変なストーリーを作っちゃえば
あのストーリーに覚えるものを入れちゃうんですよ
で 覚えられます  8 復習すること 9
実行すること 覚えたものはやってみたり
試してみたりする 実験したりする
そうすると忘れられません
この 9つは記憶術なんです
だいたいこれだけと思いますよ
はい これはまあ今日は時間があったら喋る話になってましたけど
仏教の世界ね もうちょっと皆様にはちょっと難しいかもしれませんだけどね
仏教的記憶術 昔の仏弟子たちは記憶の達人でした
暗記文化 釈尊が現れてから
ほぼ 100 400年後までは仏教を暗記して守ったんです
ほぼ 400年間暗記で
活字よりも暗記を信頼したんです
あの昔からもう文字があったんですよ
しかし 仏典は文字にしないんです
暗記で守るんです 経典のスタイルを調べると
記憶する技を発見することができます
だから私は今技を 9つ教えたでしょう
経典から経典を読むと見えてくるんです
アーナンダ尊者が記憶力の第一人者なんですね
テープレコーダーみたいんですよ
というか 現代的に言えばICレコーダーみたいですね
全部覚えているんです
それはオーディオメモリなんですね
フォトグラフィックメモリではないんです
仏教ではオーディオメモリなんですよ
フォトグラフィックメモリはもう大したことないんですよ
深い論理は語れません
ものさ 知ってますかね
私は日本語の単語を知らないんだから
英語の単語を入れちゃったんです
時々人間の中にいるんですよ
何か見たらそのまま写真を覚えちゃうんですね
あれが記憶力よりもちょっと脳の異常なんです
オーディオメモリが正しい記憶能力なんです
仏教は複雑な教えなのに
グラフ チャートなどはありません
仏教ないんです 文字だけ
だからフォトグラフィックメモリは使わないんです
現代ではみんなね チャート書いたり
円書いたり 八正道に何とか円を描いてくだらんことをやってますけど
私もだいたいチャート書かないでしょ
時々日本人はもう漫画文化だから
何かチャートを書いた方がいいなと思いますよ
でも 私の能力ではちょっと難しいんですね
私は理論で覚えているんです
理論というのは形ないんです
時間もかからない 私は今日のテーマはまさか 40 分で終わるだろうという心配まであったんです
だって私にとっては 2 3 分の知識なんです
だからそういうふうに覚えて覚えるんですよ
だから私にも本当はこのチャートグラフを書くことはできないんです
で これは仏教の世界で一有意義であること
これから学ぶ教えは 絶対的な価値のある生きとし生けるものの役に立つ
暗黒の生命世界に現れた真理という太陽である
凡夫が聖者に昇格する力のある
生きる苦しみを乗り越えられる
完全たる解脱に導かれる内容であると皆納得しているので
有意義は二重丸なんです
だから我々仏教を勉強しようと思ったら
有意義でないと覚えられないでしょう
仏教ほどの有意義なものはないんだと
えらい自信があるんですね
だから覚えられるんです
覚えているんじゃないんですよ
覚えちゃうんです 覚えるために脳は必死になります
私の脳も同じなんですよ
仏教のことを理解しようとすると
ものすごい必死になっちゃうんです
他は全部いい加減 論理性とストーリー
仏教は一方的に説かれる神の言葉ではありません
仏教はあなたと対話するのです
仏教っていうのは あなたと対話するんですよ
理解したものは自分の知識であり
自分の発見なのです そこでブッダの話を聞くと
今の経典を上げて開けて読むと
ブッダが俺と喋ってるんですよ
お前はねとかね これなんだと思うのかい？とかね
そういう風にその気がするんですよ
結構怖いとも感じますけど
対話するんですね お釈迦様が
それでわかるでしょ わかったら
それは私の知識なんです
私が発見したものなんです
だから自動的に覚えているんです
覚えることはいたって簡単
そこで物語ができちゃうんですね
物語ない場合は 様々なたとえ話を駆使した物語があります
どうしても経典の中で何がしの物語があるんです
物語でない場合は 注釈書を書いた人々は無理やりに物語を作るんです
私はそれに結構ケチをつけてますけど
この人やってない この人でやってないとかね
でも長老たちは一人作るんです
なぜかというと あれは裏技です
覚えるための 仏教は次第説法と言います
これは脳に理解できるように順を追って語ることです
私の講義と違いますよ
仏教はちゃんと次第説法なんです
必ずわかってくるところ
わかっているところから始めて
高度な真理 それから超越した境地という順です
まず 誰でもわかっている
あなたがわかっているところから始まるんです
それからどんどんどんどんわからないところまで案内するんです
ものすごく順を守るんですよ
ハチャメチャ語りません
仏弟子たちの頭が完全に理論的に理性的に成長するので
覚えておくのは朝飯前
そこでもともとバカであった弟子でも
お釈迦様が丁寧に次第説法すると
頭に頭に論理性が出来上がっちゃうんです
知らないうちに そこでもう覚えているんです
内容を観察すると さらに論理性が強くなります
だから仏教の場合は 内容を理解しようしようとするたびに
論理性が強くなります
理性が上がります で 発見の喜び
仏教は闇から光へ導く教えです
話を聞く個人は 目からウロコが落ちることに感激します
あの経典にいつでもフレーズがあるでしょ
最後にお釈迦様 暗闇の人に灯火を与えたように
迷っている人に道案内したように
よくぞ教えてくれたよと
あれは自分で発見した喜びなんですよ
結構経典の中に繰り返しこの文句があるんです
目からウロコが落ちるということは
キリスト教の言葉ですけど
まあしょうがないんですね
自分の人格が向上することに
生きるべき道が見えてくることに感動しますよ
宗教と違って依存 信仰
克服はありません 仏教では
弟子は無知を破って自分を征服するんです
自分に勝つことが最大の勝利です
この喜びが記憶力を作ります
だから仏弟子 仏弟子たちは何の苦労もなくお釈迦様の教えを覚えちゃったんです
明確にこの裏技があったんです
自分で理解しちゃうんです
それで感動するんです
うん まあ時間です その他の技は読むだけで終わります
経典の言葉にはリズムがあります
オーディオメモリーは可能になります
決まっているスタイルで語ります
用語などは決まっているスタイルで順番で現れます
覚える 語彙を洗練された詩句が多い
え？覚える語彙 なんかですね
覚える言葉 語彙ですね
で 繰り返しフレーズが必ず多数です
実践は絶対的条件 仏教界では記憶力は今も生きています
今も言いますよ 達人たち
巨人たちは 気づき サティとは解脱に達する実践方法ですが
仏教は記憶にもサティと言います
サティの実践でデータをありのままに知ることができるようになるのです
そちらに因果関係が見えてくるのです
因果法則を発見する人には当然記憶能力も現れるんです
だからサティの実践すればいいんです
記憶力を上げたいならサティの実践することです
サティの実践で記憶力は上がります
感情を不善から善に変えてみる
記憶したものを忘れるのではなく
感情との縁を切る 学ぶときは常に有意義か否かという...ん？あ
ふるいにかけてみる 復習する
実行してみる 真実を知りたいという意欲の明かりを消して消さないこと
以上 はい どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]ありがとうございました
本日はあの九時までとなっておりますので
終了の時間は必ずさせていただいます
申し訳ありません それでは皆さん
最後に回向の文を読み上げさせていただきます
お静かにしてください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬意し
彼を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖国 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして 偉いが減らますように
サッビーティヨー イワン ジャントゥ サッブローゴー ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワットワンタラーヨー スティーディー
ガー ユコー バワー バワトゥ サッブ マンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブ デワター サッブ ブン
ダヌバーヴェーナ サッブ ダンマヌバーヴェーナ サッブ サンガヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティー バワン トゥ
テー アビワーダナ シーリッサ ニッチャン ワッダー パチャイノー チャッターロー ダンマー ワッダンティー アユワノー スカンワラン
どうもありがとうございます